My son
never showed mercy.
They are prey
We are predators.
Your mother is dead.
She died because you sent her away.
She was weak, sick in her mind.
You know my business? Yes.
Power is about strength.
If you show weakness,
you will give our enemies an opening
shoot
He is weak like his mother.
Leave him.
What happened that day?
I stared death in the face.
For the first time, I saw my true self.
Tell me about this hunter.
They say he uses a connection with animals
to track his prey.
Once you're on his list,
there's only one way off.
The six of us. Only one of you.
There's six of you now.
Why do you hunt?
My father puts evil into the world.
I take it out.
Think you're some kind
honor. You were exactly like our father.
Just another man hunting for a trophy.
Murderers
is not what he taught us.
You don't get to do that to me anymore.
Mr. Tackling.
Mr. Teglin.
Where's Mr. Teglin?
Oh, you're standing in him
your goddamn lunatic.
You just figure that out Now.
There is an animal.
And each one of us.
Don't you want to know why
they call me the rhino?
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie, Marvel
and Sony just released a new Kraven,
the Hunter trailer with Aaron
Taylor-Johnson's
new Kraven is part of all the Spider-Man
spinoff movies that Sony is developing
in the Venom verse.
This is located in Venom's universe,
along with the Morbius movie.
Pretty much any other movie
doing like the Madame Web
movie will also be located
in this universe as well,
they're basically solely
introducing more villain movies.
This is going to be rated R,
so there is like a Red Band trailer.
I'll do a video for that
because it'll be some separate footage
and they're just a little bit
more hardcore as you'd expect.
So be sure to subscribe to get that.
There's so much stuff
to talk about in this trailer.
Like you can make all the jokes you want.
It's more Ben time. It's Kraven time.
I do think the idea that they're going
to let this be rated R like venom
should have been rated R venom.
Let there be carnage at carnage
should have been a rated R movie.
makes me a lot more hopeful
for this kraven the Hunter movie than say,
for like morbius
there is a lot of Spider-Man
references in here, but not quite as crazy
as in the Morbius trailer,
so I don't think they're going
to be cutting a ton of Spider-Man stuff
out of this
between the trailer
and the actual release later this year.
but it will be interesting
to see how they tie all this Spider-Man
related stuff in references into this
and how they tie it to the Venom
movies as well.
probably
some kind of crazy post-credits scene.
there's a couple of Big Spider-Man
villains in this, too,
as you probably noticed,
like the Rhino, for example.
So we'll just start at the beginning
the trailer
and work our way through, shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments
and how this is connect
to all of the Spider-Man movies.
They started the trailer with him as
an adult, getting ready to go after a car
standing on the ledge here, you notice,
he's running through traffic barefoot.
He does have low level powers
like think of Captain America,
super soldier level powers.
not quite as strong
as someone like Spider-Man, for example,
but way stronger than normal human.
Probably one of the other
big reveals of the trailer
is that Russell Crowe, of all people,
is playing his father did not expect
Russell Crowe's to show up in a Sony
Spider-Man related movie.
part of the idea
in the trailer is that he's training them
to be as hardcore as he is.
Like he has this philosophy.
He talks about their mother,
which is a bit of a comic book
reference to Kraven's mother went insane
and his father put her in an asylum.
During the full red band
version of the trailer,
they actually discussed that like you see
what seems like their chateau
as they talk about their mother
being sent to an asylum going insane.
it sounds like based on the way
they talk about her in the trailer,
she went to the asylum and died there.
And that's why
they're pissed off at their father.
but that's part of the idea.
You see him arguing with his brother, who
is playing the chameleon from the comics
about how bad their father is.
You're turning into our father basically,
which is a very common trope of these
father son superhero stories,
even for villain origin stories.
Do They're trying to position Kraven in.
The trailer is more of an anti-hero
type of character,
the same way they did with the Venom
character.
whole idea is that what Russell Crowe,
as his father does seem way, way worse.
And probably the main
antagonist of the movie, if not the Rhino,
all the different crews
that he's taking down,
all these different people
sound like they're associated
with his father because he's he's talking
to his brother, the chameleon.
He says, Our father
put all this evil in the world.
I'm trying to take it out of the world.
sounds like he's going after
all of his father's people In the rhino
is one of those people
like you see when he's a young boy
here, when Kraven is getting his powers,
his origin story,
you see the Rhino character
before he becomes the rhino standing
next to his father, you see them down in
Africa hunting big game.
His father is trying to teach him
how to hunt.
Is a boy then the way they're explaining
his powers.
His origin story here
is that he somehow bonds with the animal
like the animal DNA, bonds with his DNA,
as opposed to the comics.
What was more of a potion
that he took that gave him his powers
like he's
hunting this lion in almost fails.
It almost kills him.
But then somehow he bonds with his blood
and that gives him his connection
to animals.
Part of his powers is animal like powers,
so to speak,
you kind of get the reference here
like he was bitten.
Like Spider-Man was bitten.
He got the spider bite.
They gave him his powers.
Kraven was bitten by the lion.
He got his powers from the lion bite,
so to speak.
Later in the timeline,
you see the Rhino character
before he's become the rhino
asking about this quote unquote hunter.
So it sounds like he doesn't know
what's going on with Kraven yet,
but it sounds like he's
somehow associated with Kraven's father.
So it's this whole idea that Kraven's
going after all of his father's people,
but his father's people like the Rhino,
don't quite know what's going on at first.
This mystery bad ass with all kinds
of crazy powers is coming after all of us.
Who is it? Oh, it's right. It's your son.
This person is foreigner
from the Spider-Man comics,
but he's mostly is silver sable associate.
Like they were married at one point.
The interesting thing is
that Sony was making a Spider-Man
Silver Sable spin movie
along with the Black Cat solo movie.
But at one point they combine
those two characters in the same movie,
but they haven't said
much about that recently.
there are a couple of Easter eggs,
like Black
Cat showed up in that Spider-Man
No Way home ending scene
where all the characters in the multiverse
almost wound up on planet Earth.
Like all the silhouettes you see, Black
Cat was one of them.
part of the idea is that you see comic
book accurate versions of the characters,
and that's meant to tease
some of the movies that they're working
on, like The Rhino, the comic book
Accurate Rhino shows up in that, too.
this is also meant to be a comic book
accurate Kraven Now we're seeing a
kraven movie with that character on screen
with another version of the Rhino
this scene is part of the footage
that they showed off at Cinemacon earlier.
I talked about this in one of my first
look videos a while ago.
the version they showed off at Cinemacon
was like the R-rated Red Band version.
It was way more hardcore.
he winds up biting one of these dude's
noses
often uses a trap, a really medieval
looking old school trap on another one.
there was an image of him in the vest
earlier that league
the people weren't really crazy about.
We'll see what it actually looks like
when we see him running around in this.
later in the trailer he does get a comic
book accurate version of the costume.
And I think that's
what people wanted to see.
So they are showing it in the trailer.
he does eventually
look a little more accurate.
the claw he wears around his neck on
the necklace is meant to be
from the lion that almost killed him
and gave him his powers.
looks like he got super ripped for this
role.
this is calypso, who's a long time
kraven associate in the comics.
He's a voodoo priestess.
It also kind of drives his hatred of
Spider-Man with a lot of her magic powers,
this is another version of the rhino later
in the timeline,
seemingly before he's become the rhino
it seems like
he's still talking to Calypso
when he says he's taking the evil
that his father put in the world out
as he's taking this rhino's crew out.
it's not really clear what kind of
an organization his father runs.
during the comics.
His family, the Kraven's family
were former aristocrats.
they might be saying
their backstory in the movie
is that they used to be former
aristocrats, and his father just runs this
international evil organization
that is slowly dismantling
part of the idea
with his tragic back story
is that his family came
from wealth and power,
but that slowly weight, like their family
lost their wealth.
talking to a version of the chameleon.
It'll be interesting to see
if he also becomes the chameleon
during the course of this movie too.
Like he gets his origin story as well.
I remember when Spider-Man Far From Home
came out, that mystery character.
People thought that he was going to be
the chameleon so much.
There were so many fan theories
about this.
turned out to be a random dude
when he's an adult, he goes up against
his father will be trying to see
if that's going to be
one of the big final battles of the movie.
They're hyping up this rhino fight
like it's going to be a big thing, too.
So the rhino might wind up
being the actual final bill.
And you can let me know in the comments
what you think love.
All the spiders,
obvious spider Spider-Man reference.
Part of the idea is that
he absolutely hates he hates spiders.
So then he meets spider man in that
just drives his hatred of him further.
the one of the reasons
why he's sort of fighting Spider-Man
initially is because he was searching
for another challenge.
I think they're trying to give more
of a basis in reality in the movie.
Like if he eventually does go
after Spider-Man
with a version of the Sinister Six
that assembles,
they're trying to create a better reason
for that within this Venom universe.
But we're still kind of wondering who
that Spider-Man is going to wind up being.
Will it be Tom Holland's Spider-Man?
Will it be Andrew Garfield,
Spider-Man or Amazing Spider-Man?
However you want to think about that.
I did a bunch of videos
when Morbius came out
because there were so many Easter eggs
pointing to Andrew Garfield's
Amazing Spider-Man
enduring Amazing Spider-Man two.
There were a lot of things
that were meant to set up.
A lot of the stuff that they're doing now
in the live action movies,
like Have They done Amazing Spider-Man
three in their original Sinister
Six spin off movie
that they planned on doing?
They would have been doing this stuff
years ago,
one of the funny things
here, though, is it
seems like he's being engulfed by spiders.
I think they might just make him terrified
or just really pissed off
when he thinks of spiders in the future.
Just that kind of funny thinking about it
that way.
Oh, it's not you, Peter Parker.
He doesn't hate you.
He just hates spiders.
So any time you put the mask
on, he's really going to hate your guts.
a good way to think about
this is like an Indiana Jones
versus snakes kind of situation,
like a very bad quote
unquote encounter with a ton of spiders.
Left him
sour on spider for the rest of his life.
Then he puts on the comic book
accurate costume.
And if it wasn't clear
this is a lion's mane,
the lion's mane that almost killed him,
that he turned into this jacket
basically tagline, isn't a comic book
characters, it's just him
as part of his father's organization
and some person that he comes to kill
then they have the rhino reveal explaining
that he's going to be
a biological version of the character,
and they'll use a serum
to transform him into the rhino.
You got to let me know
what you think of that.
I'm sure there's going to be
some people out there that were like,
I actually enjoyed Paul Giamatti
version of the mechanical Rhino,
even though it was meant to be so comical
and over-the-top.
I feel like whatever they do
in this movie, they can only go up like
you can only go up from that Paul
Giamatti performance.
Even Kevin Foggy,
when he gave notes on Amazing Spider-Man
two, was talking to Amy Pascal here.
You should change a couple of things here.
These parts of the movie
work, these parts don't work.
And they took some of his notes,
not all of them.
One of his notes was he was confused
why they were trying to work in the rhino
stuff, like, why are you using this Paul
Giamatti rhino stuff?
You should just cut that out
as you can imagine.
They did not listen to him.
They left the Rhino stuff in Amazing
Spider-Man two.
But because they had that big Sinister
six teaser with The Vulture in Morbius
in the Morbius Post-Credits scene,
I feel like we're going to continue that
theme in these post-credits
scenes for the Kraven movie
they'll be some scene tying him
to some of those characters,
maybe not all of them,
but at least one of the other characters
one of the interesting details,
though, is that in the trailer,
you notice him
scratching names off the list.
Don't be surprised if he has Spider-Man
or Venom or one of the other Sinister
Six character's names on his list,
like Morbius is name on his list.
So let me know if you think that's
how they're going to tease him
crossing over with Spider-Man or Venom
or these other Sinister Six characters
that was seen the logical way to do it.
if you spotted any of the Spider-Man
or Venom references or Easter eggs
in the trailer
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
really big reminder
to Marvel Secret Invasion Episode
one is releasing this week.
I'll be doing videos for all the episodes.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channels
so you don't miss that.
My Episode
one video will post on Wednesday.
click.
Here for the Flash movie Alternate
ending in a bunch of Superman Deleted
scenes Alternate Post-Credits scenes
with a bunch of Justice League characters,
and click here for my brand new secret
invasion trailer, video and Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!